hi I'm Callie and before we get into my
review of the Last of Us part two
there's one note I wanted to make about
the embargo due to some embargo
restrictions around spoilers parts of
this review are intentionally vague I've
done my best to explain certain parts of
the game and my critique without
discussing any story spoilers but if you
want to understand the full context of
some of the analysis here we'll have
another review up when the Last of Us
part 2 is officially out and that will
discuss the story in greater detail and
further explain my thoughts the score
won't change it'll be the same it'll
just be a deeper more detailed analysis
of the game for anyone who wants to
understand a little bit more some of the
nuances here and without further ado
here's the review at the beginning of
the Last of Us part 2 you get a glimpse
of Ellie's life in idyllic Jackson
Wyoming if it weren't for the walls
surrounding the town you could almost
forget that the world is crawling with
infectious monsters that can kill
everyone in sight its main road is a
charming row of old buildings with decks
for sidewalks more Old West town than
post-apocalypse settlement its residents
grow food care for horses ten bars and
even have dances and movie nights for
years after Joel saved or rather
kidnapped Ellie from the Firefly
Hospital this is the life he wanted for
her The Last of Us part two grapples
with Joel's decision not through Joel
but through Ellie this life is clearly
not enough for her she's distant and
brooding obviously conflicted about
something she's changed a lot and when
everything falls apart and she sets out
in search of vengeance you see her pain
in its rawest most brutal form
it's a devastating gruesome story of
revenge in which the purpose of violence
gets muddied by its intensity but as a
character study the Last of Us part two
is beautiful and haunting and I found
myself completely overwhelmed by the
emotional weight of it in some ways I
mean that literally the game gave me
stress nightmares not because you kill a
lot of people per se but because playing
as Ellie felt more like being dragged by
my hair than being a merciful mission
from the very beginning I wanted to
reach out and shake her and get her to
do anything other than what we were
about to do
I knew her revenge quest was bad news
before the killing and maiming really
began
there are narrative reasons for that
though and they do work being helpless
as a player in the face of Ellie's
destruction serves a grander purpose
that I won't spoil here the biggest
issue is that the most impactful of her
kills occur in cutscenes rather than in
combat and that obscures the purpose of
combats more upsetting aspects the Last
of Us part twos combat is tense and
exhilarating though confronting in its
brutality Ellie is scrappy and agile and
moving through a combat arena is an art
her movements are smooth enough that
they almost look scripted you can duck
and dodge in a fight and deliver a
return blow with a series of button
presses that translate into a strangely
graceful dance you could accidentally
alert an enemy to your presence only to
slip through a tight space in the wall
vault through a window and outrun your
pursuer through a building to
reestablish your cover and gain the
upper hand you can also easily get
surrounded and die horribly whether
you're fighting people or infected
navigating any given combat scenario is
a puzzle in which you have to figure out
exactly how to get from point A to point
B with the resources you have I'm
partial to stealth when possible and
it's especially rewarding to decide how
you're going to silently kill each enemy
with only a flimsy silencer two arrows
and your default knife you can also find
yourself going up against both humans
and infect it at the same time and this
is when combat is properly fun instead
of just tense by throwing a bottle you
can draw a clicker toward an enemy
soldier and simply wait for them to kill
each other
you can shoot glass above an enemy's
head to send a runner or two straight to
their location you can simply take
advantage of the chaos and start
shooting indiscriminately regardless it
makes you feel clever and giddy and
weirdly proud of yourself
of course that's if you numb yourself to
the guttural screams of the man whose
arm you just shot off or the awful
gurgling sound of someone drowning in
their own blood
enemies use each other's names and
aren't shy about crying out when they
find their friends David or Rachel or
whoever lying face down in a pool of
blood suddenly dead from your silent
knife takedown killing someone's dog is
a priority as they can track your scent
and maul you to death but you have to
hear them more in the dog in real-time
it helps or maybe doesn't help that the
game runs flawlessly even on a standard
ps4 so there are no hiccups to dampen
the viciousness but like I said the
kills that actually matter in the
broader scope of the story happen in
cutscene some are triggered by a button
prompt are preceded by a brawl but it's
all very controlled it's not like you're
killing these important people in a
regular combat scenario and then
realizing with horror later what you've
done these are the kills that end up
hurting the most and they're going to
happen no matter what you do or what you
think of all the violence that's why
they work so well for the story but that
also leaves the rest of the blood showed
rather unexamined frankly the fact that
your enemies have names doesn't make
them any less in your way you have to do
what you have to do to get to the next
location and you want to do that to see
where the story goes next this
disconnect between the video game II
aspects and the grandeur narrative is
compounded by looting and collectible
hunting looting during the fight is
exciting especially when you find the
one extra bullet you need or a bit of
health that can keep you going but more
often than not
I'd loot and look for collectables only
after I'd killed every enemy in the
vicinity it's far easier and safer for
one and I didn't want to miss any of the
interesting subplots found in scattered
notes and photographs just because I
wanted to kill fewer people finding
collectables and piecing together the
stories held within them is rewarding
and paints a picture of the outbreak as
it developed through the years a lot of
the time seeking out these collectables
will force you to get creative things
like breaking windows to bypass a locked
door or swinging on a cable to get to an
area that's just out of reach there's
nothing so difficult you feel like a
genius for figuring it out but it does
make you feel appropriately resourceful
most of the time there aren't any
collectibles to find in combat heavy
areas but there are still notes and
things to find when enemies are around
and as a result I ended up scouring
every corner of every area in the hopes
of finding something cool because most
combat arenas give you multiple avenues
of attack and escape though I ended up
backtracking through most of them to try
to find things and that can
severely disrupted the pacing the nuts
and crannies that work well in combat
just become one more place to look for a
note or trading card and the fact that
you're looking for trading cards at all
often feels too gamy for the otherwise
sobering tone look what I found
isn't it one of those superhero cards
you're all into I ended up enabling an
accessibility option called high
contrast mode to help with my
collectible hunt when toggled on it
mutes the background removes textures
and highlights interactable objects and
enemies I would use it after clearing an
area of enemies to speed up the looting
part and while it wasn't the most
elegant solution it did help the pacing
it's one of a litany of accessibility
options - which allow you to fine tune
the gameplay sound and visuals to your
needs
it's a commendable suite that's
incredibly inclusive in the second half
of the game these exploration issues
persist as do the horrors of combat and
violence but for reasons I can't explain
due to spoiler restrictions the
narrative shifts significantly at a
certain point in the context of
everything you've done up until then
changes along with it there's a lot I
want to say that I'm not allowed to
until the game is out but this half of
the game is the reason anything in it
works at all it examines a lot of the
violence that happens early on though
not all the violence in general and it's
where the story finds its meaning by the
time I finished the last of us part 2 I
wasn't sure if I liked it it's a hard
game to stomach in part because so much
of who Ellie is and what she does is
beyond your control she is deeply
complicated and flawed and her
selfishness hurts a lot of people at
times the pain you inflict feels so
senseless that it can leave you numb
it's all messy and bleak and made me
profoundly sad for myriad reasons but
the more I reflect on it the more I
appreciate the story and characters at
its core I wanted almost none of it to
happen the way it did and that's what's
both so beautiful
and devastating about it
you